we have now a little bit of data to
maybe answer the question could
disproportionate Republican coveted
deaths have flipped any particular seats
in the 2022 midterms now let me reset
this for you because we've talked about
this probably for a year or more but now
we're really in the thick of it because
we now have most of the results of the
2022 midterms we know that more
Republicans than Democrats died of covet
we don't know exactly to what degree or
by how much but we know that this is a
result of early on in the pandemic
Republicans were less likely to heed
public safety guidelines than were
Democrats therefore they got more
coveted and as a function of that more
of them died
in the post-vaccine era uptake of
vaccines was lower among Republicans
than it was among Democrats and as a
result of that more Republicans died of
covid generally speaking and so the
question of whether this impacted the
election results is really a
mathematical question first you've got
to figure out to what degree were
Republicans dying of covet more than
Democrats it seems like now it's it's
twice as much so we could call it two to
one J you could zoom out and say okay
twice as much means roughly
two-thirds of the coveted deaths were
Republicans one-third of the coveted
deaths were Democrats got about a
million deaths okay so again we're very
much zooming out when a 12 year old dies
you don't assign a party affiliation to
that right but we're speaking super
generally
out of a million you would say well
that's like 666 000 Republican deaths
333 000 Democratic deaths again these
aren't real numbers because you've also
got non-voters in there and kids Etc
that means that the Gap means about 333
000 more Republicans than Democrats died
assuming everybody is a voter and is an
adult so then you've got to figure out
of that 333 000 Gap are there any
particular districts where the Gap alone
or any particular States for Statewide
Senate and gubernatorial elections where
that death difference alone could have
flipped a seat we don't really know the
answer yet but it's increasingly being
studied
um we uh there is a well actually Vice
wrote this up and they are not the
authors of the study but we'll link to
this article the study is called excess
death rates for republicans and
Democrats during the covid-19 pandemic
and they looked at death records They
looked at voter registration and they
said what is the link here between
political affiliation covet deaths and
the impact on the midterms now I am
going to come out and and right up front
say a couple different things
it is completely possible that the
margins here
were between Republican and Democratic
deaths in particular congressional
districts for example weren't actually
big enough to really flip any elections
maybe they were maybe they were not
there are some who are saying that it is
just filthy to even be asking this
question I completely disagree with that
um you're you're not making Light Of
Anything by on top of all of the obvious
personal and family tragedy that our
covet deaths to to ask the political
question and say could this have shaped
the electorate in 2022 it's a completely
reasonable question to ask so don't
don't be swayed by the Republicans who
are turning up their noses and saying
how offensive how offensive to even ask
the question there is really nothing
wrong with asking the question the next
part of this is it would be interesting
to actually get some some specific
numbers you know we
in the lead up to 2022 I used an example
from Florida's last gubernatorial
election and in Florida's last
gubernatorial election the margin
between Ron DeSantis and then Democratic
candidate Andrew Gillum was very small
and based on that margin
the disproportionate Republican covet
deaths in Florida could have made a
difference but that was in the last
election the margin was so big in
DeSantis defeating Charlie Crist last
week that the covet deaths would not
make a difference it was a 19 Point uh
win for Ron DeSantis so the theoretical
example I gave about Florida from the
previous election it really doesn't
apply because the margin was so big so
generally speaking
even if there were no specific races
that depended on the partisan split in
Cova deaths this may become a larger
component of Republican demographics
related to vaccines Beyond covid given
the growing anti-vaccine sentiment that
is developed in the Republican Party
since covid more broadly we might
actually start to see this particularly
over time be a factor you know we've
said before there are demographic
changes happening in Texas where Texas
is becoming a Bluer as a result of
demographic changes there may also be
changes to the electorate forced in by
anti-vaccine sentiment it shouldn't come
as a huge shock that this is sort of the
conclusion to what has been quite
frankly Decades of Republicans
increasingly denying science
increasingly telling themselves
scientists are just sort of like liberal
professors you can ignore everything
they say and bring your own opinion and
your own opinion is just as valid as
theirs
seeing that grow for decades should then
not make a surprise now at what we are
seeing at some point we will probably
get a more specific answer was there any
particular race that arguably was
flipped by disproportionate Republican
covet deaths we don't have the answer
right now but it is being studied